six people have been killed than 200
have been injured during a protest in
the Indonesian capital laughter the
result of the presidential election was
announced in Tuesday evening the Central
Election Committee confirmed the victory
of current president Joko Widodo however
several thousand supporters of his
opponent retired military general
proverb Basu Bernardo took to the
streets
severe Anto claims there was widespread
cheating and he's going to challenge the
results police used tear gas on some
demonstrators who refused to leave the
area after the end of the rally as they
started to throw objects at the police
you